are reviews that are paid for by the
product in question ethical the boss in
charge of publishing the recent indie
game Spirit T took to Twitter recently
talking about launching the game and one
of the topics was how he didn't manage
to get much of any coverage for the game
because YouTubers will often only cover
games if it is explicitly paid for but
what interests me about this is how the
conversation was received online hordes
of YouTubers and fans alike took to
outrage with exclamations of you expect
them to do work for free so let me
quickly break down the problem here
journalism of which YouTube reviewing in
fact falls under must necessarily remain
independent an objective review already
barely exists but an objective review
that was paid for certainly doesn't
exist now that's what the say paid
coverage should be shunned what that is
is not reporting it's advertising which
is fine it is a necessary part of the
ecosystem but the two are to remain
separate lest reviews and journalism
cease to exist entirely